Democrats alleged the president Trump
colluding with Russia
stole the 2016 election according to a
new public opinion poll most Republicans
think the Muller probe is a witch hunt
perhaps because President Obama
installed a mole on the Trump campaign
the beautiful game wraps up in Russia as
the real beautiful game of politics
kicks off in Helsinki at the Trump Putin
summit we will analyze then Brits try to
nix brexit and ariana grande proves Pat
Robertson right on feminism and
witchcraft
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
so we've got the conversation coming up
that's coming up very soon with the one
and only Supreme Lord of the multiverse
Andrew Clavin make sure you tune in for
that that will be coming up here is mr.
Clavin to tell you about it hey there
fellow Cleveland fans if you're like me
I know you're incredibly excited to find
out what I'm going to say in a new
episode of the conversation on Tuesday
July 17th at 5:30 p.m. Eastern
you can catch our live stream on
Facebook and YouTube and if you're a
daily wire subscriber you get to ask me
questions about issues like these how do
conservatives take back the culture
everything that left us is magnified
because they have the megaphone of the
press I don't understand why otherwise
smart educated people support leftist
ideas so much because they don't hurt
them Ben says that he finds friends kind
of useless
I find friends to be one of the great
great consolations of wealth so
subscribe now and you can ask me live
questions on Tuesday July 17th at 5:30
p.m. Eastern join the conversation can't
wait for that
also you know we've got to turn to our
sister network daily wired to pretty
soon to Jeremy the god-king boring
before we do that gotta make a little
money honey well you know you know look
you look at my face you say how do you
have such baby soft supple skin Michael
well the answer is Dollar Shave Club
that's how the best racer that I've ever
used in my life and all of DSA's
portfolio products are really good
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything
you need to look feel and smell your
best it has everything you need to get
ready in the bathroom any you know any
aspect of your body so obviously you're
shaving they have really good stuff they
have that wonderful dr. Carver's shave
butter that works really well
they've got shampoo they've got
conditioner they've got body wash but I
do have to talk about look we've been
very European recently every roll of
Americans loving soccer watching the
World Cup well you know one thing
Europeans do they have that B day you
know they really take their hygiene very
seriously from head to toe and Dollar
Shave Club offers you a similar thing in
one wipe Charlies so make sure you get
those one wipe Charlies if you're what
once you sit down you know you're tuned
into the beautiful game you're going to
want to make sure you use your one wipe
Charlies to
it is really good I'm tell all jokes
aside Dollar Shave Club it is the best
razor I've ever used I used it just this
morning I use it all the time
and I always use nice razors but this
one this is just the best I think the
the executive razor has 700 million
blades on it I'm not I haven't counted
exactly but it's something like that
there really it really works very well
here's a great way to try a bunch of
Dollar Shave club's products for just 5
bucks you can get their daily essentials
starter set it comes with body cleanser
one wipe Charlies the portable bidet and
the world-famous shave butter and their
best razor the six blade executive Oh
it's 6 ok 6 blade keep the blades coming
for a few more bucks a month
add in shampoo toothpaste anything else
you need for the bathroom never have to
run to the drugstore again a thing that
I would never do so I would just use
rusted over blades for years at a time
don't do that make sure you order this
it's a really great deal and great value
dollarshaveclub.com /co f fa c OV e f EF
e dollarshaveclub.com / co f fa c OV e
fe fe without further ado i need to know
what happened in the game let's turn to
our sister network daily wired to and
jeremy the god-king boring yoga is a
pagan sex ritual Michael as has been
pointed out ad nauseam by comment trolls
since this bit first began the femme
fatale world cup is a true world cup in
which well-paid players from squads all
over Europe change jerseys and play up
their grandmother's accents to represent
the districts beyond capital city in a
televised deathmatch with indecipherable
rules meant to provide circus for the
masses
while the muckety-mucks eat until they
barf and then eat some more since it is
a truly global competition it seems
appropriate to take instruction from the
foremost citizen of the world and the
first US president not born on this
continent Barry Soetoro
who ignoring the actual Christian faith
of dr. Martin Luther King jr. scolds us
that the archivist of moral the arc of
the moral universe may bend toward
justice but it is not doing so on its
own indeed it does so by way of money
and in the end might finally made right
even in the World Cup with France GDP
two point four six trillion dollars
in Croatia with its GDP of roughly 50
billion pretty much destroying every
funny joke about the World Cup
fortunately we here at the Daily wire -
managed to secure an interview with one
of America's top soccer players to
explain what went so wrong for Croatia
and so right for basic capitalist
principles well here we are with one of
America's foremost soccer experts let me
ask you what is your favorite thing
about the beautiful sport what did you
make of jerusem
okay well here's a better question
Croatia has a GDP of fifty point four
three billion dollars their chief export
is transport equipment how do you think
that factored into their match up with
friends who's three chief exports are
cheese wine and cowardice hmm well I
guess the only question in the aftermath
of France and Croatia's final will
Germany rise again
that's all the time we have Thank You
Ben for that very important interview of
course the biggest news of the weekend
was not France being on the wrong side
of history
it was FIFA's bold and courageous
decision to stand up to the patriarchy
by no longer giving women any screen
time whatsoever at future World Cup
matches in an official statement foo-foo
president Eduardo on the take claimed
that women have no place at the World
Cup unless they are homely and
inseparable in which case it's still
okay to show them as long as you pay
them exactly zero percent of what you're
paying the male players who are far less
interesting to watch feminists the world
over celebrated the news that American
men would no longer have any reason
whatsoever to tune in to this
mind-numbing snooze fest
by crack tackling like Angry hens about
how evil men are for no longer tuning
into this mind-numbing snooze fest the
trans community objected to the news
that women can no longer be shown that
soccer matches simply because they look
like women by reminding us that while
the gender pay gap is real gender is not
and that looking like a woman is pretty
much the definition of womanhood that's
just science
US President Donald Trump responded to
the announcement that hot babes would no
longer get airtime at the World Cup by
pulling America out of hosting the games
in 2026 calling America's traditional
allies losers and asking Republicans
super donor Elliot Brody for the number
of that playmate he definitely didn't
have sex with and that's all the news
for the 2018 World Cup I want to give a
special thanks to Twitter handle strange
land elf for being lovely in every way
and for not flying to Los Angeles and
killing just before today's broadcast
and to the six or seven people who
actually thought this bit was funny
soccer truly sucks and Germany will rise
again Michael Yoga is a pagan sex ritual
back to you
really is the best part of the sport
really thorough reporting Jeremy thank
you so I was really taken all around the
world with that I'll confess to being
pretty much out of jokes that doesn't
mean we're gonna stop the segment Oh God
no absolutely not that would never hold
that against us I do have to wonder
though so France won the World Cup is
this not the great triumph of this
segment that we've done that for weeks
can a sport be a sport if France can win
it that's a fair point yeah I always
feel bad for our friends the French I
mean after all they they did help us win
the American Revolution that was the
last war in which they showed heroism
bravery backbone spine of course it
worked out well for us that's true and
then all the people that helped us in
that revolution by the way promptly had
their heads cut off about ten years
later that's right as we now fly the
flag of the flag of the French army
really thorough reporting Jeremy I can't
wait to keep talking about this
important beautiful game when will the
next soccer match be that we can watch
and talk about I'm gonna have to be just
plainly honest with you Michael don't
know crap about soccer I don't know who
plays it or when they built this
brand-new Stadium in Los Angeles I don't
think that's for the World Cup it's
still eight years from now who knows as
far as I know I will say that according
to social media a lot of people do go to
soccer matches at said Stadium which is
somewhere in Southern Cal well like I
have to give you a lot of props though
mr. god-king because your network our
sister network daily wire - yeah really
did stream phenomenal coverage of all of
the game over the weekend and people can
go check that out I really liked it at
daily wire - calm so maybe people can
check that out mr. Godkin I can't thank
you enough you've really shown me the
light on this beautiful sport and great
news that President Trump is reacting to
the cancellation of babes in that way I
can't wait for the United States never
to host the World Cup he is constant as
the North Star
yeah Jeremy the god-king boring
everybody daily wire - thank you very
much
Bam Bam pagan Yogi's and pagans next
ritual really good speaking of the
beautiful Games in Russia speaking of
the beautiful games let's talk a little
bit about the beautiful games of
international politics because that
really is the beautiful game and a
Hemingway had this great quote about
games he said there are only three
sports bullfighting motor racing and
mountaineering all the rest or merely
games and a more Hemingway quote I don't
think I've ever heard
politics is a beautiful game it is a
game it's not it's not a sport the
distinction that Hemingway is drawing
was between something where you really
could die you know your life is really
on the line and then games you know and
what we're seeing now is not war we're
not at war really we're not see the
Trump Putin summit is not about war
precisely the Trump mulher probe is not
about war the Democrats and Republicans
are not at war we're in games and the
politics is a high stakes game but it is
a game and everything you've been
hearing over the past few weeks the
Muller indictments the curiously timed
Muller indictments all the way up to the
the Trump arrival in the United Kingdom
all the way to Trump meeting with Putin
and Helsinki it's all about games and
what is the thesis of the game the debt
the Democrats play here from just their
side is that the president colluded with
Russia that is that's their position
that's what they're staking out that's
how they're gonna play this game and we
have some video of it don't we of the
president colluding with Russia let's
see it
[Music]
[Music]
no no not when President Obama said that
he was going to mislead the American
people when he promised that to the head
of Russia on it on camera he thought he
was having a private conversation I'm
talking about the other time that the
president colluded with Russia you
warned us about this and you said
there's about a hundred and forty five
million in kickbacks to the Clinton
Foundation total yeah that's right 145
million dollars that we know about comes
from a variety of sources but it's
basically nine shareholders in this
uranium one company guys like Frank
Giustra Sergey kurzon and in others and
there's there's a major story to be told
there not only about how this deal was
approved but how this deal was put
together and the fact that the Clintons
made a lot of money by basically helping
the Russians to corner of the world
uranium market no I'm not talking about
that time that former future president
Hillary Clinton helped the Russian took
a lot of money by helping the Russians
to corner the global uranium market I'm
not talking about that I'm talking about
when the president colluded with Russia
just like all the Democrats have been
saying I established I think of an
effective working relationship with mr.
Medvedev and as a consequence Russia's
economy was growing they had the
opportunity to begin diversifying their
economy their relations across Europe
and around the world were sound they
joined the WTO with assistance from us
and since mr. Putin made this decision
around Crimea and Ukraine not because of
some grand strategy Governor Romney I'm
glad that you recognized that al-qaeda
is a threat because a few months ago
when you were asked what's the biggest
geopolitical threat facing America you
said Russia not al-qaeda you said Russia
and the 1980s are now calling to ask for
their foreign policy back because you
know the Cold War has been over for 20
years well I was looking for the tape of
President Trump colluding with Russia
maybe the producers in the back and try
to find that we just found a bunch of
Democrats colluding with Russia
President Obama and then former future
president Democrat Hillary Clinton they
did and and this really does expose the
whole Russian narrative as a force it's
a political game
and they're playing that game and that's
fine but that's the position we're in
there these are not honest brokers here
not the Democrats not the media perhaps
not even the bureaucrats who are who are
pushing this narrative too there is a
big political game going on we're gonna
see who's gonna win the stage that's
being played out on is Helsinki
president Trump is getting a lot of
flack from the left and from his critics
on the right but it's a it's really
undeserved this is a game so we'll see
how the game is being played let's let's
go right in to president Trump meeting
with Putin before the before anything
got started here before the private
meeting before the press conference
afterward they held a little presser a
little meet-and-greet beforehand and
I've got to tell you you know how it
started off in the right way because
President Trump made fun of soccer here
it is
a really great world cup one of the best
ever from what everybody tells me one of
the best ever and also for your team
itself doing so well I watched quite a
bit in the United States we call it
soccer and I want quite a bit of it and
I watched the entire follow and the
seventy finals and they were really
spectacular games but it was beautifully
done so congratulations on them so on on
the level I don't want to read too much
into this you know on the ninety eight
percent of what this is it's just a
nicety you know trying to what do you
say about somebody who's like a vicious
KGB killer who poisons people with
polonium you know you're just sort of so
the games were nice right but he did get
these kind of barbs in the hair which is
like first of all he implied that he'd
never watched soccer before which is
obviously true cuz nobody has watched
soccer before he also said he refused to
call it football or release it you know
we call it soccer in America that little
weird thing that you kids do we call it
soccer we do that and but he also said
that the ones in Russia were some of the
best ever which is obviously true that's
I think a little bit of a backhanded
compliment you know damning with faint
praise but he opens up he says yeah yeah
soccer it was good it was good it was
good and I got to tell you from the
beginning here the the narrow part of
the Democrat game is that Donald Trump
is a total total nincompoop
he's a total incompetent idiot
politician and they you can't have it
both ways been pointed this out on the
Bill Maher show the other day the
Democrats angle here is both the dumb
Trump is a total incompetent nincompoop
and also he's a political mastermind
genius who colluded with Russia and you
can't have both you have to pick one
you're not allowed to have both
Democrats are trying to push both a
narratives right now they're trying to
push it so that any way Trump turns he's
he's trapped by this Democrat playbook I
think we all have to conclude Donald
Trump is a great politician he's a
really good politician he's good at
politics he's even good at political
speech here is just a quick example of I
think the most basic level of political
speech politics 101 I noticed this in my
early days working on campaigns and I'll
just I'll show you this is how President
Trump is exemplifying political talk I
think we have great opportunities
gather as two countries that frankly we
have not been getting along very well
for the last number of years I've been
here not too long that it's getting
close to two years but I think we will
end up having an extraordinary
relationship I've been saying and I'm
sure you've heard over the years and as
I campaign that getting along with
Russia is a good thing not a bad thing
and I really think the world wants to
see us get along we are the two great
nuclear powers we have 90 percent of the
nuclear and that not a good thing it's a
bad thing and I think we hopefully can
do something about that because it's not
a positive force it's a negative force
so we'll be talking about that among
other things you see that it's a this
thing none of this thing this is
political speech 101 and it plays out
differently with different people
because in order to effect a political
agenda
you need to throw issues into stark
light now what kind of mealy-mouthed
people do what Barack Obama likes to do
sometimes when he's being called out for
not dealing properly with Russia or
whatever is he says well it's very
complicated it's very nuanced it's
really and you can't so do Purdue to do
okay when you're trying to obfuscate
that's what you do when you want to call
things into stark light and achieve
something politically you say it's this
not this it's black and white and what
what dishonest politicians do by the way
is they whenever they say that whatever
thing is that phrase like I want to
lower your taxes not raise your taxes
whatever they say after not is what they
really want to do it's not like slimy
politicians do it's like look I I want
to help alleviate poverty not just help
out the rich right now as it's always
just the last one and but Donald Trump
is an honest politician he's honest to a
fault I think his critics on the right
and the left both say this they say he's
too you know he's too clear and what he
says I say I'm gonna cut taxes he cuts
taxes I he says he's gonna point her
originalist he points an originalist he
says he's gonna try to work things out
with Putin he tries to work things out
with Putin he says he's going to destroy
Isis militarily he destroys Isis
militarily he's really honest he's got a
good record on keeping his promises this
is something new it's why people don't
really understand Donald Trump that well
is because what he says he's going to
give you is
he actually gives you the
press-conference then afterward is being
pilloried they're saying john mccain
sent at this blistering statement you
know john mccain pulls no punches as
though john mccain ever pulled a punch
him he's always criticizing the
president he has a penchant for
criticizing people in his own party and
he's always issuing grandiose statements
he says it's the worst press moment ever
in the history of the president say in
my lifetime it's terrible wham I went
right okay was the press conference
perfect no I don't think anybody says it
was perfect broadly though it's good and
President Trump really achieved
something important here which is forget
about the Putin thing it doesn't really
matter they had their private their
private meeting and the United States is
gonna pursue its interest Russia's gonna
pursue its interest we'll see if we can
get along probably we can't but maybe we
can the the achievement the president
that President Trump had in this press
conference is he fended off the Democrat
attacks and he offended off their game
strategy the Democrat game strategy is
to put him in a corner such that
anything he does is a loss for Trump if
he hits Putin that's a loss if he if he
plays soft with Putin it's a loss that's
what they were trying to do he fended
that off very well here's just a little
bit from the press conference the
disagreements between our two countries
are well known and President Putin and I
discussed them at the length today but
if we're going to solve many of the
problems facing our world then we're
going to have to find ways to cooperate
in pursuit of shared interests they also
did trade some Barb's you had to be
watching us closely but they did trade
some barbs here you know president from
coal to Putin a global competitor they
said do you really think he's a
competitor some of the Russian
journalists said do you really think
he's a competitor he says he absolutely
is a competitor and we're gonna compete
for oil giving well to Europe right now
what Europe is buying a lot of oil from
Russia and I want to stop that and I
want them to buy more from the United
States because we're the largest oil
producer in the world we're
we're number one there's a pretty strong
statement from Trump Putin got in a dig
about Israel Putin said you know this is
actually a concession Israel said
they're going to go back Syria needs to
go back to the ceasefire from I think
1974 and it's you know basically insure
Israeli peace and security and Putin
said you know President Trump was really
specific about Israel he was really
focusing on Israel and this was a little
dig in there to try to create some
turmoil as some domestic turmoil for the
United States but just a little bit of a
line and then President Trump when he
was he was broadly deflecting questions
about the molar indictment and the
collusion and the this and that but he
did have this line I forget the exact
wording he did say like well you know
president Putin's gonna answer some
questions he's gonna look into this
there's some things being raised you
know it wasn't this total saying yes
Putin didn't interfere in our election
he said well he's gonna have to look
into that he basically takes president
Putin's denial for you know for what it
is what are you gonna do he say he says
we didn't do it and then he was gonna
say issue did you did it you did it damn
it no that blows up the whole summit but
he did get in there like well okay I
don't you know well let's see what we
believe from Vladimir Putin the media
then of course come in and they try to
trash this so the the real game here is
the media trying to blow up this summit
put Trump in a position where everything
he does is wrong by the way these
indictments came out last week the end
of last week is that a coincidence I got
to tell you you know people try to make
Bob Muller and the Special Counsel look
like he's totally above politics people
they do this with a Supreme Court the
Supreme Court's totally above politics
Bob Muller watches the election returns
Bob Muller watches the presidential
calendar and the Supreme Court watches
the election returns too that's the
long-standing political reality of
things those indictments came out on
that day to blow up the summit to blow
up the Putin from summit in Helsinki
that's what it was all about there there
are no coincidences and politics so how
did Trump do on that well here is the
the big blow up on holding Russia
accountable here's the press conference
Russia at all accountable for anything
in particular
and if so what would you what would you
consider them that they
responsible for yes I do I hold both
countries responsible I think that the
United States has been foolish I think
we've all been foolish we should had
this dialogue a long time ago a long
time frankly before I got to office
that's right that's the statement that's
the one that he's getting blown up for
he you know he said there's blame to go
around for the breakdown in Russia and
us ties and cooperation that's obviously
true he later on he says you know the
probe is a disaster for our country you
know it's a and that is it is a disaster
for our country not for Russia's country
it's not drawing some sort of moral
equivalence between Bob Muller and
Vladimir Putin a KGB killer because
saying yes this is the probe this has
been pushed by Democrats begun by
Democrats begun by Democrat Oppo
constantly touted by the Democrat media
that has been a trouble for a country
and it has strained US and Russian
relations but is there blame to go
around that's the big question is there
blame to go around for the breakdown in
us-russian relations of course of course
why are we why are we negotiating from a
position of weakness
well Barack Obama did nothing when
Vladmir Putin annexed Crimea that was a
mistake
there's some blame to go around there a
Hillary Clinton sold took money from the
Russians and gave them control over a
large part of the global uranium market
that was a mistake that that comes to
blame that effects our position
President Obama leaned in and said I am
willing to lie to the American people
I'm gonna miss Lee the American people
through my election and then I'm going
to pivot and do the opposite of what I
say I'm going to do do something
different than I'm promising the
election I'm gonna give you flexibility
that's a position of weakness there's
been a lot of blame to go around
of previous administrations not to take
a hard line the the Russian hacking by
the way took place under the Obama
administration how why didn't they stop
it why couldn't they prevent it why
couldn't they deal with it in real time
that was a mistake there's blame to go
around
and that's perfectly that's not drawing
moral equivalence between the United
States and Russia I'm very pleased that
President Trump has no is no longer
drawing moral equivalence that's a good
thing I mean he's getting better in
office but there is a lot of blame to go
around and the the past administration
in the form of future president Hillary
Clinton as Secretary of
State did a lot of damage to that to
that relationship and it's because they
led from behind because they they
negotiated from weakness so the media
still wouldn't let up here though you
know President Trump or president from
President Putin almost admitted by the
way that he did hack the election here's
Putin as to who is to be believed after
who's not to be believed you can trust
no one if you can take this where did
you get this idea that President Trump
trusts me or I trust him he defends the
interests of the United States of
America and I do defend the interests of
the Russian Federation we do have in
common we are looking for points of
contact issues where our rosters diverge
and we are looking for ways to reconcile
our differences how to make our effort
in the other meaningful that's the whole
story folks that's the whole story
they're saying the big New York Times
headline here is Donald Trump gives in
to Russia
he won't condemn Putin he won't scream
and try to rip his head off on stage
Issa sellout he gives in and Putin's
lying and getting away with it
Putin just admitted right there that he
hacked the election that's the
confession that's the big admission he
said look what do you mean who has the
question is who should we believe the US
intelligence agencies are Vladimir Putin
should we trust Putin and Putin actually
comes out and says why would you trust
me why are you trust I don't trust Trump
Trump threat doesn't trust me he's
coming at that this is the whole story
because President Trump defends American
interests and Putin defends the Russian
interests that's the admission right
there but that won't be reported on will
it because you know you never wonder
with the Democrats if it's malice or
idiocy but
either they're very obtuse or they're or
they just didn't understand what flight
and Putin is saying there the media
still wouldn't let up here they're
begging him they're saying come on
Trump blow up the whole summit
teleporting off do it do it do it area
are there would you now with the whole
world watching tell President Putin
would you denounce what happened in 2016
and would you warn him to never do it
again
all I can do is ask the question all I
can do is ask the question yeah that's
right that's it obviously what do you
want me to do I mean Trump is sitting
there like are you an idiot what is to
be gained what is to
from Trump going on the stage and saying
you tried to spy on our election and
interfere with us and and then they say
okay well there goes the summit why did
we have the summit at all I mean the
Muller indictments coming out when they
did was to stop this summit they don't
want the summit to happen but what's to
be gained from that does anybody on
earth really believe that Russia didn't
try to interfere in our elections
Russia's been trying to interfere in our
election since 1917 do we really think
that all of a sudden they stopped
interfering in the 1970s 1980s you had
Ted Kennedy trying to collude with the
Russians to help his presidential
election you had kissed Henry Kissinger
was talking to the Russians obviously
the notion that they're not interfering
in our elections and that we don't have
strategic interests to spy on the
Russians is absurd of course everybody
spies on each other that's just the way
it is they got a good one this time sad
you know but what does that mean that we
shouldn't have any diplomacy now because
a nation is spying on us because a
nation is aggressive because the nations
in trying to interfere in our elections
and we're interfering in other elections
and we're spying on other people perhaps
that means that we shouldn't have
diplomacy that's absurd and they
wouldn't believe it if this were a
Democrat president they would absolutely
be saying great and finally diplomacy is
winning it's it's just a political game
and this is why you shouldn't get too
riled up about this folks if you're on
the left or the right this is a game
that is being played out by the Democrat
Party and the Republican Party you know
ironically here ironically here the New
York Times is actually commending Donald
Trump and they're commending because
they can't ignore it anymore on this
foreign trip he actually the headline
from the New York Times is Trump got
from NATO everything Obama ever asked
for
it shows the game for what it is because
if Barack Obama we're doing this things
they would be cheering the the Democrat
Party wants to put Donald Trump in a
position where if he if he is too nice
to Putin or he's diplomatic with Putin
then it's evidence that he colluded even
though we've seen no evidence that there
was any campaign collusion and what
they're trying to do is back him into a
corner where he has to be extremely
aggressive with Putin which will hamper
his agenda to try to court to try to
first of all bring the nations closer
together and to cooperate where they can
either way it's a lose-lose for Trump
Trump's not going to do that that's a
big win that's a big win and you know
here's the New York Times now that the
smoke is cleared from the NATO's
meeting the most tangible result is
apparent president Trump advanced
President Barack Obama's initiative to
keep the Allies on track to shoulder a
more equitable share of NATO's costs mr.
Trump even signed on to a tough
statement directed at Russia for once he
saw eye-to-eye with his predecessor yet
whether mr. Trump himself is clear about
the strategy he's pursuing or whether he
in fact has won remains mysterious of
course you know they've got to get their
knock and Trump is an idiot right that's
from the New York Times but on actually
what he's getting it seems that he's
getting the right things you know Barack
Obama sent campaign advisers to try to
stop to try to interfere in the Israeli
election and kick out Bibi Netanyahu we
didn't hear anything about this because
this is a political game and I think
fortunately was this a clear win for
president Trump and the administration
was this at clearing notch it up a park
maybe not but he won and he fought back
and there's in it we should not be
criticizing him for that because to to
do that is to deny their actual stakes
of this game and to deny the reality of
it by the way this brings us to this
brings us to the brexit so we all
remember brexit
oh gosh do we have to I really want to
get to these indictments we just have
too much today all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna analyze the indictments tomorrow
but broadly speaking I read through all
of those Muller indictments there's
politically timed Muller indictments and
what they show is that the what the
Democrats are trying to show is that
President Trump called out and he said
hey Russia if you find the emails you
know let us know and then they started
packing that's not true what the
indictments show us very clearly is that
the hacking started way before him but
it started in March President Trump
didn't make those those comments until
the late spring and summer that started
in March they spear fished they started
hacking they were hacking for a very
long time CNN says Trump asked Russian
to get Clinton emails they immediately
started trying just not true all of this
is about this ultimate game is about
overturning a democratic election you're
seeing this in the brexit before we
before we go and then I'll analyze
ariana grande right now there is a
campaign remember the brexit when the UK
is supposed to leave the European Union
you might not remember because it hasn't
happened yet and the reason it hasn't
happened is because just like the left
and America is playing their game the
left in the UK is all
playing this game to undermine a
presidential order to undermine a
democratic election there was a
referendum campaign the British people
said we want to leave the EU so what has
George Soros done he's announced a new
push for a new referendum they say we
need a new referendum why because the
first referendum didn't go his way
didn't go their way he said quote
ultimately it's up to the British people
to decide what they want to do it would
be better however if they came to a
decision sooner rather than later that's
the goal of the initiative which I call
best for Britons what I support that
they already had they already decided
they already had their voices heard and
they just didn't give you the answer
that you want so now you got to do it
again they do this again and again this
pro-eu a Member of Parliament Justine
greening wants a new vote and what the
left wants to do they want to keep
voting they want to keep counting until
they get their answer the election
results come in and the and the numbers
aren't in their favor I'll just keep
counting keep on counting keep on
counting right away it's anti-democratic
it's being played out through the Muller
probe it's being played out through the
mainstream media it's being played out
on the global stage and Helsinki it's
being played out of the brexit we
shouldn't fall for it you have to know
the rules of the game if you're going to
win the game and denying the game that's
being played is not the way to do it
it's a it's a beautiful game politics
but you've got to look at it with a
pretty clear eyes and what we've got
here is basically a win at least in this
round we've still got a win and it's
much more beautiful and entertaining and
important than soccer
we will we've got to get to ariana
grande we're running late today folks go
to Daley wire.com right now if you're
already a subscriber thank you you
helped us keep the lights on you keep
khofifah in my cup if you're not go it's
$10 a month $100 for an annual
membership you've got me
the Andrew Clavin show the ben shapiro
show you had to ask questions in the
mailbag look if you're saying I just get
the updates on YouTube and that's great
not watching on YouTube they're
colluding against you pal you got to go
over there right now YouTube is trying
to shut us down and even if you've
subscribed you might not get
notifications that were on so you got to
go and you got to ring the bell you had
to click the little bell on YouTube and
then you'll start getting notifications
again until they find some other way to
try to kill us so go to daily wire comm
because again as none of that matters
this is what matters the leftist here's
tumblr this is like a nice a nice tastes
like a mixture of borscht and vodka it's
really
this time I call it the help the
Helsinki vintage go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back to explain how
ariana grande is a witch
in our remaining moments here I want to
turn to the question forget the question
about politics forget the question about
Russian collusion it's got a woman
that's that's what ariana grande is
alleging if you haven't seen her new
music video here's just a clip and we
will analyze it
[Music]
it's a little racy can we are we like to
play that on the show
I don't know play it again so this song
that ariana grande has come out with
ariana grande I think is about four
years old I don't know she's like 25 or
something she was like a teeny bopper
and now she's you know big pop star and
I actually kind of liked some of her
work I think she's got like a real sense
for pop music which you know I'm gonna
this is this is worse than liking soccer
for my masculinity card but this song is
really crazy because it's extremely
cultic so God is a woman obviously it's
a very provocative statement also not
true and you see all of this imagery
throughout the music video people are
saying it's so weird they don't get it
you get this weird like flame thing and
a bunch of screaming groundhogs and
Ariana Grande sort of caressing in a
sensuous way the storm system moving
over the globe what does it all mean
what does she mean by God is a woman
where does this come from
it's really really cultic like pat
robertson
joked about this and by joking i mean he
probably really believed this that
feminism is tied into the occult it's
tied and let modern leftism is tied into
the occult ariana grande is kind of
proving that point here you know you
immediately get all of this anatomic
imagery so you get like this flame that
looks kind of anatomical you got this
watery paint bed that has certain
designs the storm system and it reminds
me of Georgia O'Keeffe if she was the
one who painted very anatomical looking
flowers you know when you go to the
Georgia O'Keeffe museum in Santa Fe you
have to watch this video right up front
and they say you know Georgia O'Keeffe
people thought she was painting women's
anatomy but that isn't true and then you
go look in every single painting is
pretty graphic and contradicts of video
that's what you're getting here you're
getting a lot of Georgia O'Keeffe
imagery and a lot of cultic stuff it
comes from it reminds me of like
Gilgamesh you you get you know kind of
this feminist I guess would it be like a
sacred prostitute this appears in
Gilgamesh appears in the Bible a lot of
ancient religions had these sort of
sacred prostitutes and you get a lot of
imagery in here and I was thinking I was
like am I reading too deeply into this
am I don't know the video was released
on Friday the 13th
jezus like Friday was the is the witches
Sabbath in the occult and you know
obvious
everyone knows the the for what Friday
the 13th symbolizes and then later on in
the video you get this book it's all of
these men sort of screaming at her it
from a book and she's sitting there like
the thinker this the the statue of the
thinker and it which is based on the the
sculpture by Rodin and it's for a
doorway surrounding the gates of Hell
which is based on Dante more kind of
cultic dark imagery men are throwing
words at her in the book that they're
standing in is a history of agriculture
sees men in history the history of
cultivation it's written in French but
it's the history of aggravator had a
cult so this point is pretty sure that
that's what's going on then ariana
grande appears in front of this
three-headed dog Cerberus it would have
calls to mind you know this dog of the
underworld when you try to come for me I
keep on flourishing she says really you
know poetry and then there's this crazy
scene where these groundhogs just jump
up from the ground this dry earth and
start screeching in this awful voice and
so I read a piece on pytheas a great
website that has a lot of religious
stuff by Matt Oren who is a gay male
which to do with that what you will and
he says that this is all an a reference
to the pagan holiday of in bulk which
coincides with the Christian holiday of
candles and it's a celebration of the
this goddesses return to the land to
bring water to this dry land and the
light taking over the darkness and you
see a total one-for-one in the imagery
there the imagery of groundhogs today
the light taking over the darkness and
the dry land and then the water imagery
immediately comes afterward and then
there's another image of ariana grande
like a like a she-wolf and like the
little kids Romulus and Remus sort of
suckling from her and I hope I'm not
making this sound sensuous it isn't it's
pretty pretty gross looking but I was
really shocked by this because all the
times you're these right-wing sort of
people say pop culture is awful it's
perverting the minds of people it's
cultic it's this it's that you kind it's
just so easy to brush them off and who
cares do I think that a whole generation
is going to be destroyed by some stupid
music video no but it is all cultic
imagery it does really have a point and
very easily in our political discourse
it's easy to brush things off and say oh
you're thinking too much
you're well you know who else thought
too much the person who made this video
they were thinking a lot too they were
putting images they're pretty
intentionally there are a lot more
references in it we don't really have
time to get into but it does really make
you think I did this video for Prager
you where I said you got to watch your
language
people say oh who cares if you use
illegal alien or undocumented him or who
cares it's just semantics those words
those little things they really matter
one of the characters on the crown a
couple seasons ago he said you know it's
in the small things that the wrought
begins you got to really look out for
that and it totally reminds me of of
that pat robertson quote perhaps you've
heard it I'll leave you on this note
today because we got to go but it is the
greatest quote in political history from
Pat Robertson he's the squinty guy in
the Christian Channel he says the
feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women it is about a socialist
anti family political movement that
encourages women to leave their husbands
kill their children practice witchcraft
destroy capitalism and become lesbians
I'm not going to unpack that I'll let
ariana grande do that for you I'll let
soccer which is an outgrowth of that do
that for you but I'll leave I'll leave
you on that note today we've got some
great guests coming up this week I can't
wait for you to tune in for it now we've
covered all of the political gamut for
the last three days but we can get back
to more broader things tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt chin is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua all Vera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you